so die Unzufriedenheit mit der Regierung
sie wächst sogar der ehemalige
Bundespräsident Joachim Gauck hat nun
deutliche Worte gefunden zur Gefühlslage
der deutschen
deshalb brauchen wir kraftvolle
politische Führung die gleichzeitig im
Stande ist das was sie im Sinn hat und
tun wird auch den Menschen so zu
erklären dass sie es wirklich verstehen
und wir haben im Moment so ein volatiles
Situation dass eben sehr viele Menschen
das Vertrauen verloren haben und darum
brauchen wir ganz klar gesprochen nicht
nur die Ansage der zeitenwände die
unglaublich wichtig war sondern wir
brauchen auch eine Politik die dieser
Ansage entspricht
deutliche Worte also die
klimaextremisten immer wieder blockieren
sie den Verkehr kleben sich zum Beispiel
auf den Boden und jetzt gehen sie noch
einen Schritt weiter auf der A2 Richtung
Berlin Bremsen Sie den gesamten Verkehr
nötigen damit andere Autofahrer
Christkind mit riskieren mit dieser
wahnsinnigen Aktion einen Massencrash
gefährliche Aktionen auf der A2 zwei
Autos bremsen den Verkehr runter in den
Wagen diese klimaaktivisten wir sind
hier mit unseren Autos heute um ein
Tempolimit einzuführen auf der A2
und wir machen das weil wir nichts uns
gefallen lassen von meine wichtigen dass
er sagt er hätte keine Schilder mit der
Politik sind sie nicht zufrieden also
initiieren sie am Samstag diese
verrückte Aktion Bremsen mit zwei Autos
den Verkehr auf 100 km/h runter das
alles filmen die Aktivisten selbst und
posten das Video bei Youtube doch damit
gefährden sie die unbeteiligten
Autofahrer hinter ihnen provozieren im
schlimmsten Fall einen Unfall die
Polizei stoppt bei Magdeburg zwei Autos
hat nun ein Strafverfahren wegen
Nötigung gegen die beiden Fahrer
eingeleitet
sprechen wir darüber und zwar mit Rainer
Wendt er ist Chef der Deutschen der
Polizei Gewerkschaft schönen guten Tag
Ihnen Herr Wendt das ist eine Aktion die
kann ja durchaus gefährlich werden für
alle Beteiligten dort auf der Autobahn
dann einfach das Tempo so sehr zu
drosseln wie oft sehen wir auf deutschen
Autobahnen Auffahrunfälle die alles
andere als gut ausgehen
ja das ist ein neuer Höhepunkt dieser
Aktion der
klimakriminellen anders kann man sich ja
gar nicht nennen denn was da begangen
wird sind schwere Straftaten die
Menschen Leben gefährden und wir haben
ja in der Vergangenheit ähnliche
Aktionen erlebt dass Menschen sich von
der Autobahn haben runterhängen lassen
dadurch den Verkehr gefährdet haben oder
aber die fast schon berüchtigten
klebeaktionen in den deutschen
Großstädten auch und vor allem in Berlin
das ist jetzt ein neuer Höhepunkt und
der zeigt vor allen Dingen dass der
Kampf um die Aufmerksamkeit der Kampf um
Medienbilder voll entbrannt ist und dass
diese verrückten sich nicht beeindrucken
lassen durch Polizeimaßnahmen oder auch
durch die Justiz das was bisher als
Antwort des Rechtsstaates gekommen ist
reicht ganz offensichtlich nicht aus
Ermahnungen Geldbußen Geldstrafen
darüber lachen diese Leute hier müssen
Haftstrafen endlich kommen und die
müssen dann irgendwann auch mal
vollstreckt werden was wünschen sie sich
da konkret darüber hinaus
ich wünsche mir zunächst einmal dass
sofort die Fahrzeuge eingezogen werden
die Führerscheine sowieso wie das gehört
alles dazu wer den Straßenverkehr
missbraucht um seine eigenen kruden
politischen Botschaften und das Volk zu
bringen und wer vor allen Dingen das
Recht in die eigene Hand nimmt und das
im Straßenverkehr tut der ist
selbstverständlich charakterlich völlig
ungeeignet zur Teilnahme am
Straßenverkehr mit einem Fahrzeug
deshalb müssen die Führerscheine weg und
die Autos müssen auch eingezogen werden
denn die sind genutzt worden um diese
schweren Straftaten zu begehen aber dann
muss die Justiz ein klares Wort sprechen
das heißt die klimakaoten müssen wissen
wenn Sie Menschenleben auf diese Art und
Weise gefährden dann ist der Rechtsstaat
in der Lage sich zu Wehr zu setzen und
durch harte Urteile dann auch eine
Antwort zu finden wenn irgendwelche
Ermahnungen kommen so auf dem Niveau von
Fernsehverbot das reicht auf keinen Fall
aus hier muss der Rechtsstaat deutlicher
werden damit wir auch vor Gefahren durch
diese Chaoten geschützt sind woran liegt
werden zu Vorteile gesprochen nimmt man
das ganze nicht ernst oder fehlen die
Instrumente die
Rechtsgrundlage versorgen
ohne Gesetze sind schon gut der
Gesetzgeber hat in Strafgesetzbuch harte
Strafen vorgesehen nicht nur Geldbußen
nicht nur Geldstrafen und Ermahnungen
sondern durchaus auch Freiheitsstrafen
im Fall von Nötigung oder wie hier darf
man ja durchaus auch den gefährlichen
Eingriff in den Straßenverkehr annehmen
da sind hohe Freiheitsstrafen vorgesehen
bislang ist das alles noch nicht erfolgt
weil die Gerichte ganz offensichtlich
glauben dass man mit abgestuften
urteilen Eindruck auf die Beschuldigten
machen kann das ist ganz offensichtlich
nicht der Fall was den Hintergrund hat
dass diese Leute kämpfen um
Aufmerksamkeit und zwar um jeden Preis
sie wissen dass die Diskussion zurzeit
völlig andere sind man redet über den
ukraine-krieg man redet über
Energiekrise und vieles andere mehr da
wollen die Aktionen dieser verrückten
nicht so richtig in den Mittelpunkt
rücken und deshalb werden sie immer
gefährlicher immer spektakulärer weil
sie in den Blickpunkt der Medien
gelangen wollen und da muss schnell
Einhalt geboten werden der Gesetzgeber
hat die Strafen dafür vorgesehen jetzt
muss die Justiz das richtige Wort
sprechen
Rainer Wendt vielen herzlichen Dank für
Ihre Einschätzung zu diesem Thema
[Musik]